und sie sehen jetzt meinen kollegen
kolja gärtner ganz schreckliche bilder
die wir gerade im film gesehen haben
julia kannst du uns noch mal ganz kurz
beschreiben was ist genau passiert und
weißt du denn schon mehr
ja also ich konnte jetzt gerade eben
noch mal mit der polizei sprechen ist
hat es gegen 13 uhr 24 ist zu diesem
unfall kam
nach zeugenaussagen haben sich hier zwei
lamborghinis und ein porsche auf der
dreispurigen autobahn von wiesbaden nach
frankfurt die andere richtung
offenbar ein rennen geliefert ein
lamborghini fahrer verlor auf mal die
kontrolle über sein fahrzeug prallte in
die mittelleitplanke schleuderte zurück
erfasste dann ein opel und ein bruder
der skoda ging in flammen auf dort drin
ist eine person verbrannt der fahrer des
lamborghini und warum werden wir
ebenfalls die beiden männer befinden
sich banken aus
die polizei fahndet jetzt nach dem
zweiten lamborghini der nicht am unfall
beteiligt war so wie hier an der branche
es gibt leider keine beschreibung eine
nähere beschreibung der verfärbung
ergänzen
da die zeugen an natürlich ihre
aufmerksamkeit weil erst mal gericht
illegale autorennen das macht auf jeden
fall wütend sowas müsste nicht sein und
dann auch noch mit so einem horror
ausgang wie sind denn jetzt die
ermittlungen ermittelt die polizei in
dieser richtung weißt du da was ja also
es wird es wegen eines illegalen
autorennens ermittelt es ist auch die
staatsanwaltschaft eingeschaltet wir
haben hier also im hintergrund keinen
normalen unfallort sondern tatsächlich
ein tatort
deshalb werden die arbeiten hier vor ort
auch noch eine ganze weile weitergehen
die autos werden und den beteiligten an
diesem auto rennen drohen zehn jahre
haben wo das opfer gegeben
[Musik]
dabei verursacht
wir werden sehen was in diesem fall also
passieren wird wir werden hier bei bild
natürlich berichten kohle gärtner
erstmal vielen dank an dich für deine
informationen und einen schönen abend an
dich trotzdem wir sind bild und wir
liefert dir deine news auf youtube zum
nächsten video kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren